foreign
information drenched society that tempts
us to choose unhappiness over
uncertainty it is helpful to remember
that one of the key Gifts of travel has
always been uncertainty itself
I could have been paraphrasing you I
feel like we talked about this or that
that's a phrase that I know is probably
not too foreign to you no it's not and
this really falls into the idea of of
preparation versus leaving yourself open
to chance which is really the gift of
travel
and that goes into the ideas of flurring
your way through a city or using
psychogeography to surprise yourself to
sort of force yourself into being
surprised by a place because in a way if
we bring a menu of options to a place
then we're sort of bound by the size and
of the menu and what's on that menu
whereas if we throw the menu away and we
just and this is a metaphor not just
talking about food if we're open to any
kinds of experiences
then you can experience what you didn't
expect to find like once I was wandering
through Cambodia and I had a lot of
great experiences back in my Dirtbag
Backpacker days and I'm a pretty tall
guy I was like the tallest guy by a head
in Cambodia and I got invited to a
volleyball game because these local
villager guys thought I would be the
ringer and ladies and gentlemen I've
never had my ass handed to me in sports
so much by these guys in Cambodia who
were so much smaller than me they
actually kicked me off the team they
brought me on as a ringer and they
kicked me off because I'm I'm reasonably
athletic but these guys just loved lived
and breathed volleyball and actually
Asia is a great volleyball culture if
that's your sport and so I think had I
gone into that experience just with my
anchor watt map I wouldn't have had that
deep humility that came and then the
friendship that happened afterwards you
know the beers the guys I made their day
by being the six foot three guy who was
just completely inferior to them in
volleyball and that's just one of many
experiences where you just
one of my mantras is walk until your day
becomes interesting because then things
happen to you instead of going with
expectations about something that will
happen to you you just sort of walk and
and what happens happens you let go of
that uncertain deal to a little bit
because sometimes we're sort of task
driven people back home but why not just
let a day breathe why not just walk
until you get your ass handed to you in
volleyball or somebody wants to invite
you to uh to a festival I mean
this happens more often in places where
you're obviously not from there I think
I was a little bit spoiled by spending
the first eight years of my
international travel career in Asia
where I don't look very Asian and so I
was on a statement of the conversation
yes you do not look very Asian this is
true I do not look Asian and so I had
the privilege and it really is a
privilege of obviously not being from
this place and so it's like let's talk
to this dude he's not from here right
and so it gives so many rewards and I
feel like that scab that uncertainty
scab I peeled off a long time ago
because it's been so rewarding in life
and I think maybe Asia cured that of it
it's just like here's here's the Pasty
guy let's go bring him to our parents or
let's go include him in this soccer game
or let's go see if he wants to eat these
these boiled fish eyes or whatever and
it just makes it makes the experience
more interesting and so I think
sometimes the uncertainty isn't really
uncertainty in the face of danger but
just uncertainty in the face of not
having a list of things to do and not
having a set itinerary for a given day I
love museums but at the end of the day
it's those weird random getting your
butt kicked in volleyball moments that
are much more memorable and lead to
these connections that no amount of
certainty
could give you and that's what
uncertainty does give you
are there any particular tactics or
recommendations let's say somebody
agrees with us they're like I totally
agree with what you're saying every trip
I've taken has been pretty tightly
scheduled
what do you suggest right so you can
walk until the day becomes interesting
and get lost especially in a place like
Japan I mean it's so safe generally
speaking it's uh fantastic plus the
English at least when I was last there a
few years ago I mean the English level
tends to be quite low so you
automatically get more excitement that
way and do you have any other
suggestions I mean one thing that came
to mind for me for instance I was like
look if if you're in Japan you get and
you're wandering at getting lost and
let's say you don't find a cool park or
this that other thing some big
obvious
point of focus you could also just
decide you know today I'm going to walk
and get lost and I'm going to go into
every convenience store and try to
notice the things that are different
in those convenience stores because they
are quite different even if you go into
say a 7-Eleven in Japan they are not the
same as the 7-Eleven in the United
States and that might sound really
stupid but you you start to notice a lot
of little details and any other
suggestions for injecting some
uncertainty if somebody wanted as funny
as this might sound you know
instructions for injecting uncertainty
yeah well I think to your 7-Eleven in
Japan example people who are in a hurry
to get to those five tourist attractions
don't have time to to linger in the
7-Eleven and see how weird there's those
bean paste sweet things that you buy
there right oh yeah and so really slow
down if you have if you have 10 days in
this country spin them all in one town
or spend them all in one region and
don't force yourself to Rush from one
place to another one of the philosophers
I quoted in the new book is uh
byeungchol Han have you heard of uh I
think he has a book I think it's called
the scent of time oh great title yeah
well he talks about how you can't fast
forward
sense like of the five senses like
there's probably people who are
listening to this right now on double
speed or 1.5 speed you can fast forward
sound you can fast forward through a
movie right you can't fast forward
through the smells of a market right
yeah so he talks about smell is the
ultimate slow sense and basically his
his philosophy is that
it's a Swiss Korean guy
is that it's the experience of duration
that counts in life not the number of
experiences right he's actually a pretty
abstract philosopher his book is a
little bit slow to read but it's such a
great point and applies to travel so
much in that it is that day where you go
from convenience smart to convenience
Mark and see how they're different that
counts it's it's that ex it's the
duration of that day that is more
meaningful than than those five tourist
attractions that you might have gone to
before you and I have hung out in Paris
before and and actually we had a great
walk in Paris which we can talk about if
you want but oftentimes I have friends
students will come to Paris and it's
like I ordered lunch and it took them
forever to serve my lunch and then I
wanted the bill and it took them forever
I had to find the guy and it's like I
wanted to experience Paris but I was
sitting in this restaurant waiting for
my bill it's like no no no
that three-hour lunch is the experience
of Paris you know the parisians are not
standing in life for the Louvre I'm not
going to knock the Louvre it's fine but
that was the most Parisian thing you
experienced that day was sitting for
three hours and just sort of watching
the world go past you you know if you're
willing to sit still then you know you
are a spectator in daily life of the
world and so yeah yeah I think about uh
young child Han's philosophy quite a bit
that it's it's the experience of
duration if you can find ways to savor
experience to slow it down and to notice
that from that cafe table in Paris it's
just as Parisian as any other part of
the city and you can actually watch it
with more attention to detail and this
doesn't just Paris but anywhere if you
slow down and instead of moving through
a place let that place move through you
for a while it's going to be so much
more affecting